what's happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch today from our good
friend paul over at heavy spoilers the
book of boba fett finale predictions he
got a decent amount right for one
episode a while ago so i'm curious to
see what our friend gets right this time
every
wednesday at 1am we are talking to each
other which is like a comfortable 9 a.m
for him you son of a bee as we were
cranking out these boba fett videos
let's see what's in store subscribe to
heavy spoilers if you haven't done so
already and also hit the like button on
our video if you haven't done so already
let's do this
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's a bit
like boba fett because i'm the most
forgettable thing about my own show
if you enjoy the video then please hit
the thumbs up button and also don't
forget to subscribe for videos like this
every day without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
book of boba fett okay so in the latest
episode of the show we saw a harrowing
flash back to other 66. in it we watch
three jedi attempt to protect roku but
curiously we're yet to see him be saved
fully i think with this being such a big
moment we need a fan favorite to step in
and do something and having that happen
would break the internet just like luke
did upon his return now though there
were a whole host of jedi's at the
temple during the ambush i think it
would be amazing to see mace when you
come back in one of the coolest scenes
in revenge of the sith he went to
confront palpatine only to suffer from
the combo of star wars tropes which is
of course having his hand cut off before
he fell to his death though he was
hurtled through the skies of coruscant
star wars has slowly started to
establish that this isn't a death
sentence
sliced in two and he fell to his death
but fans loved him so much that they
brought him back in the expanded lore
things like this have been shown in
palpatine asaka and the only person who
hasn't come back is mace windu yeah
possibly might be wrong might be wrong
but it's a fan theory yeah so bear with
us now samuel l jackson's stock in
hollywood has only risen since revenge
of the sith and though he was popular
beforehand he's consistently stayed a
big name since he last appeared as windu
both the marvel and star wars franchises
have been bought by disney meaning you
know they might have some corporate
synergy there or something now during
star wars celebration in 2017 the actor
said we all know jedi can fall from
incredible heights and survive so
apparently i am not dead yes i have two
appendages right now you know the long
and rich history of star wars characters
reappearing with new appendages since
his statement in 2017 jackson has
doubled down further by saying that he
definitely wants to come back and
reprise the role of windu this would tie
in really well with the show as it's a
pretty safe bet that a jedi was the one
who saved grogu from the temple but he
has forgotten who it was due to the
trauma of the events i would love to see
may step in may saw the gods and though
i don't necessarily think that he made
it out of core ascent watching him go in
a blaze of glory would be an awesome
send-off for the character i mean i did
see that circulating on social media
that maybe he's the one who ultimately
saved grogu i think what a lot of fans
really want especially after the events
of clone wars and then with attack of
the clones with mace windu the heading
jango fett you know in clone wars if you
guys haven't seen it i mean i'm assuming
you probably have at this point there
were a couple of episodes dedicated to
boba fett a younger version tracking
down mace windu and attempt to kill him
to get his revenge it might be a little
too much to throw into the fidelity
where mace windu just shows up but it
seems like we're bound to get an
inevitable showdown with cad bane and
boba fett something that fans want to
see come to live action however you know
i think there's also that other payoff
of like oh what if we can actually get
something where we can get basement
versus boba fett that's something i
think a lot of you really want get some
conflict between him and din jar and
tomorrow because if he hurts season two
yeah because if he saved the child but
also has this vendetta against boba fett
that make for some good dramatic
friction very true now the question that
remains is how long has catbain been
working with the pikes in our cadbane
explainer video we discussed how there
were unfinished clone wars episodes that
showed cadbane and boba working together
before they had a fallout and then
dueled it is possible that this is now
cannon as in the bad part
bane had a plate on his head which
wasn't there when he showed up in the
main series if bane had been working for
the pikes for a while he could have
started when their first shipment was
threatened and boba demanded payment we
know that tuscans who took barbarian
were apparently killed by a biker gang
but that seemed unlikely considering how
tough the tuscans were it could have
been a false flag with kad actually
being the one who killed them and him
pinning the blame on the bikers would
further tie into their rivalry killing
the tuscans would be a big nobe
i think being behind will be something
that's revealed in the final episode
yeah that would be freaking awesome
something that sparked in my mind was
what if the opening for the next episode
is the live action version of that
showdown between boba fett and campaign
i think that would lead for something
very personal before you know the
credits roll yeah absolutely plus
they've already got the previz done
exactly exactly how to shoot it i mean
it wasn't brought to life in the clone
wars season finale so if they can bring
it to life here live action and that's
like your opening scene showing the pike
so it establishes the personal traits
and then it also gets you reinvested
back into boba's journey and would
campaign show it up and and also for
audiences who aren't familiar with cad
bane this would give them some type of
personal reason to attach themselves to
him being in the show it would be a
really cool way to do it now whilst the
show has morphed into mandalorian season
2.5 the core of the series has really
been about baba fett staking his claim
as a crime lord he has come into direct
conflict with the pike syndicate and you
might remember that they appeared in
solo a star wars story they're making a
fortune running spice on the planet
basically doing what they want it's
clear they're ready to kill anyone
including madame gaza just to keep the
spice flowing this could be a prelude to
a possible continuation of the ending of
solo and the finale may bring kira back
at the end of solo she was asked to
bring the first light ship to dathomir
where she and maul would work closely
together whilst the solo sequel has yet
to materialize this story progressed
into the superb marvel star wars comics
and we discovered in them that she now
controls crimson dawn now she has come
into conflict with boba before and
during the war of the bounty hunters
storyline he actually stole han solo
from boba whilst he was in carbonite
during crimson really
we learned that kira had been trained by
maul and she went on an anti-empire tear
in order to destabilize the imperials
out of this we can also hear some notes
from the crimson dawn soundtrack in the
theme of the show
[Music]
that is pretty neat
[Music]
i love it
put some respect on that solo much more
subtle than that and it would be great
to see emilia clark reprise her role
with her having history with boba and
the pikes 2. in crimson range he
captured a young girl who looks
strikingly similar to omega aka boba
fett's sister if she is manipulating the
pike syndicate from the shadows then
using an attachment to him would be one
shocking way to do it and because of
this i'd love to see her back i mean the
main reason i love to see her back is
that yeah everything you're saying is is
very uh valid and ubiquitous a lot of us
have thought that she might actually
return for this show at the same time
though i think one thing this series has
done is make a lot of like the prior
installments that came before both
mandalorian and boba fett feel a lot
cooler and better and more essential
viewing when they already were essential
viewing so i think you know solo a star
wars story could use a tiny bit of love
it needs that disney retroactive
improvement touch
now episode six was a gruelling entry
that tugged at the heart strings as mano
decided to leave groggu so he could
complete his training we got a good look
at the fundamental differences between
the mandalorian and the jedi because the
are a loyal to the core following their
creed rise the jedi must leave the past
behind and form a connection solely to
the force grogu is stuck between both
worlds and he can only choose one of
these two ways of life
hold on a second yet i thought this only
the sith stealed in absolutes anyway he
was offered in the armor which is a
metaphor for his past or yoda's
lightsaber which is a symbol of his
potential future though it ended the
episode on a cliffhanger if we look at
the expanded lore we can't figure out
which one he chose now in this scene
luke says
if you choose the armor you'll return to
your friend the mandalorian
but if you choose the lightsaber you
will be the first student in my academy
and i will train you to be great
he wasn't the first in the comic star
wars the rise of kylo ren issue 3 kylo
states that he was indeed the first if
this is kept in continuity then captain
obvious but it means that grogu did not
choose the lightsaber however fallonia
showed somewhat disregard for the comics
as yoda's lightsaber was destroyed in
them by darth vader boy i really hope
somebody got fired for that one comics
might be completely ignored but i do
think that grogu will choose to go back
with mando and there was a line that saw
hinted to him not really needing any
training luke stator one point to ahsoka
that he's not really learning things
he's just remembering and therefore he
already has the skills grogu being a
mandalorian jedi would also fitting very
well with the story of top issa who was
the first of his kind well groggy could
be that considering kylo did say he was
the first student it would indicate that
the little guy chose to return to his
adopted dad this will allow him to ride
in the space in the old starfighter but
it would also go beyond that mando has
been unable to wield the dark side but
because he's clearly distracted by grogu
and thus then being reunited i think
will make the weapon lighter for him as
he'll now be more focused oh that's a
great call damn
i love that thought of that yeah
i love that call expect him to write it
right away this moment is clearly being
saved for the final battle in the series
training rancors to write them is
nothing new to star wars with the
witches of dathomir having ridden them
which was given lip service to by danny
trejo on top of this he provided some
more about the rancors and how whilst
they're bred for fighting they can be
quite loving and incredibly loyal this
somewhat mirrors boba fett being a clone
as he and his brothers were born for
battle and apparently that was that
however over the course of the star wars
saga we've seen how clones have actually
built personalities and form tight bonds
with one another when he takes the
rancor and rides it he will fully become
himself no one others perceive him as
like a clone or bounty hunter but who he
has chosen to live as riding the rancor
is also symbolic showing his dominance
and taming of a wild beast just like
he'll need to tame the mythosaur if he's
to take back mandalore now with cad bane
and possibly kira being blast from the
past for baubar who else could come back
well the most obvious answer would be
han solo while the other two have been
expanded outside of the main suckers
in the original trilogy japan somehow
returns to star wars using the same
magic that was used on luke skywalker
then it would be something else as
harrison ford is probably the biggest
actor to come out of the franchise i say
probably yeah definitely now this kind
of
theory which is that lucan and leia will
be reunited on screen one final time one
thing that we never got in the sequel
trilogy exactly
i think it would massively elevate the
series if it gave us an image of them
back together han and leia might even
bring their young son ben with them and
just in the same way we saw luke's
academy being built we could also get a
tease of its downfall if they arrived
with their young son i mean that is like
the main reason to do it right hey look
the one who knocked boba into the
sarlacc pit was han solo and b we never
got even han and luke interacting with
each other but then my question becomes
is this like yeah harrison ford bring
him back that shamu guy he did amazing
deep fake technology and then i my mind
went ah poor old and aaron right yeah i
know you bring back amelia cork we're
solo a star we're sorry but we got a
deep fake harrison which you would do
something with darris and ford instead i
mean i feel like fans wouldn't be upset
about that or i mean actually it's star
wars there's going to be people
relationships probably call them around
yeah i know that at the same time though
i'm like they seem like they'd be way
more likely to just do a harrison ford
deep fakes or whatever that technology
is called so that way you can finally
pay off that thing that a lot of fans
complained about with the sequels just
like chewie's metal
finally got it
i hope you enjoyed the full breakdown
and all our predictions i do think that
bet will be allowed to remain on
tatooine because it's better the devil
you know and the republic might want
someone respectful running the crime
syndicates there rather than the hudson
pikes another fantastic job there buddy
i hope some of these come true i feel
like uh
yeah it seems likely that at least half
of these would come to you
gotta be some of them great job dude all
right man well subscribe to happy
spoilers if you haven't done so you can
subscribe to us keep a lookout for our
book of boba fett finale reaction last
but not least do a peek
adelia chamberlain adelia i know you're
a huge dune fan and i feel like this
show has been reflected more of doom
than a lot of other star wars live
action stuff lately and on top of that
too i see you on twitter i see that you
are one of the people who has been
championing for this show and showing a
lot of love for it and that was before
mando even showed up
so adelia i'm really happy that star
wars is paying off for you in a very
positive way may the force be with you
always as you transfer that spiritual
energy to us as well meeting you a
couple months ago was such a highlight
of our year in 2021 and uh just having
you be at our page is a constant
highlight for us so thank you for being
such a sweetheart and uh keep kicking
ass on all the endeavors that you're
doing you're one of the strongest people
i've ever known so keep it up okay
okay
don't mess this up
[Music]
you